a security camera captured what happened
exactly one year ago the collapse of the
dam unleashed a torrent of toxic mud and
debris which killed 270 people and left
an entire community forever scarred
volunteer rescuers such as Renato C Veda
say searching for survivors was like
being in a war zone
we found between 20 and 30 bodies in
this area alone the helicopter was
constantly going up and down taking body
parts because there are only a few
bodies found intact I found only one
body intact what we found the most was
body parts and dead animals for those
who survived recalling the events of
that day brings back traumatic memories
at the Maya Fareeda used to work for the
dams owner brazilian mining company
Valley at the Maya sister and
sister-in-law both died in the disaster
he places the blame entirely on the
mining company in addition as the
dictionary does not even have a verb to
describe an irresponsibility of this
scale the greed and cowardice because
what happened here was premeditated
I say this to you looking into your eyes
no fear of being wrong earlier this week
prosecutors in Minas Gerais charged 16
individuals worth murdered including
valleys chief executive
Fabio Schwartzman our investigation
found that Valle knew about structural
inefficiencies within the dam as far
back as 2017 but did nothing to address
the problems we hope the charges lead to
prison time for those responsible
prosecutors say that not only did Valley
know that a catastrophic collapse was
possible employees of another company
too absurd of Germany had previously
inspected the dam saying it was stable
and knowingly helped Valley hide the
truth about the risks Valle did not
agree to Al Jazeera's request for an
interview but the company did provide a
statement calling the legal charges
quote premature
adding that Valley is committed to
aiding authorities with the ongoing
investigation
eleven bodies were never recovered and
the city of Ramadi no continues to face
other challenges such as an
environmental disaster that hasn't fully
finished playing out Manuel Arevalo
al Jazeera Bru Medina Brazil